[Musica]
[Applauso]
resilienza presidenza è un termine che
deriva dalla metallurgia indica la
capacità di un metallo di resistere a un
urto senza rompersi credo che la mia
storia possa essere un buon esempio di
resilienza vista come la capacità di
perseguire gli obiettivi nonostante le
difficoltà e gli eventi negativi che ho
incontrato sul mio cammino
ma per comprendere meglio i fatti
vi devo raccontare un episodio accaduto
i primi istanti della mia vita quando
sono nata il momento di grande suspense
per la mia famiglia soprattutto per mia
mamma e chi con lei era in clinica e
avrebbe dovuto comunicare a mio padre
che era nata una figlia femmina hanno
atteso tre ore per trovare il coraggio e
comunicarglielo perché lui aveva
impiegato in nove mesi antecedenti ad
allontanare chiunque parlasse della
possibilità di avere una figlia femmina
qui è cominciato il mio percorso
in un mondo dove ci si aspetterebbe un
uomo è invece arrivata una donna a
partire dalla mia stessa famiglia
in questo caso mio padre fino al mondo
del lavoro dove appartengo oggi oggi
lavoro in azienda di famiglia sono la
seconda generazione di un'azienda
metalmeccanica di cui con grande
orgoglio sono amministratore delegato ma
per arrivare fin qui la strada è stata
lunga e tortuosa
ho svolto gli studi in economia perché
ingegneria era roba da maschi
mi sono laureata con il massimo dei voti
ma in realtà fin da subito non sono
voluto entrare nell'azienda di famiglia
ho voluto svolgere altre esperienze
lontane in due multinazionali un aroma
una milano nonostante fossero esperienze
di grandi soddisfazioni e tra l'altro
gestivo discreti budget a un certo punto
della mia vita ho deciso che fosse
giunta l'ora di entrare a far parte
dell'azienda di famiglia da bere
non potevo decidere neanche il colore
delle pelle dal 2007 al 2018
sono stati anni di affiancamento ad un
capo che non accettava l'idea che fosse
né giovane né donna sinonimi entrambi
per lui l'incapacità e così il team che
lavorava con lui fin da subito pensava
tanto e solo la figlia del capo ma con
grande determinazione lavorando con loro
e più di loro ho conquistato la loro
fiducia e rispetto di tutti ma per mio
padre non era mai abbastanza e
continuava assiduamente a ripetermi c
piuttosto che lasciare l'azienda una
figlia femmina l'avrebbe distrutta così
è stato dopo aver avuto due figlie
femmine e ancora dopo tre nipoti femmine
il destino
ha cominciato il principio di
distruzione ma questa non è solo la mia
storia è la storia di tante donne in
tanti settori soprattutto quello
metalmeccanico che purtroppo a numero
occupazionali femminili molto bassi
solo il 20 per cento di cui il 10 per
cento dirigenti ma il settore
metalmeccanico non è solo il cuore
pulsante dell'industria italiana è il
primo comparto manifatturiero che genera
l'otto per cento del pil nazionale e
crea posti di lavoro per 1,8 milioni di
persone e pensate di questi 2 milioni
solo il 20 per cento e donna non
parliamo poi quando ci si deve
interfacciare con aspetti tecnici o
trattative commerciali in paesi dove il
gender gap cioè il divario tra uomo e
donna è ancora molto ampio
un esempio è vissuto sulla mia pelle in
uno di questi paesi e una donna anche se
straniera non può parlare di business
non può far parte delle trattative
commerciali non gli viene neppure
concesso il visto
se non turistico e se non accompagnata
dal padre o dal marito altri esempi di
vita vissuta come questa i miei piccoli
progressi con le battaglie come donne in
un mondo di lavoro maschile fanno parte
di una più alta testimonianza che
insieme alle associazioni di categoria a
cui appartengo
portiamo e andiamo a raccontare nelle
scuole infatti con molti altri
imprenditori professionisti su base
volontaria dedichiamo molto del nostro
tempo libero per sviluppare progetti
dedicati all'orientamento del lavoro sia
con gli studenti andando nelle scuole
facendo con loro un gioco di ruolo e
cercando di rispondere ai loro dubbi che
hanno verso il mondo del lavoro sia
progetti di incontro confronto rivolti
ai neet neither in employment non in
education or training
vale a dire ragazzi che non studiano e
non lavorano non so se sapete che i neet
in italia sono più di 2 milioni di
questi 2 milioni sono il 40 per cento e
donna in questo caso la percentuale
bassa perché le donne sono
più brave e più presenti nel mondo
scolastico anche se la forbice si
ribalta subito dopo nel mondo del lavoro
da dove vengono tagliate fuori in più
volte su 100 ragazze 97 frequentano un
percorso il secondo ciclo contro il 94
per cento dei maschi tre punti
percentuali in meno
il 56 per cento di queste frequenta
percorsi liceali contro un terzo dei
compagni maschi
non parliamo poi del mondo universitario
dove su 100 ragazze 57 svolge il
percorso universitario conto solo il 46
per cento dei maschi ma la disparità
grande e nella scelta del percorso
formativo perché le donne prediligono
ancora per corsi umanistici mentre gli
uomini preferiscono concentrarsi su
percorsi tecnico scientifici e per
questo che spero che la mia
testimonianza in un mondo altamente
tecnologico quello metalmeccanico e di
un passaggio generazionale molto
complesso caratterizzato da forti
pregiudizi di genere possa essere di
stimolo motivazione ispirazione alle
ragazze alle donne che studiano e che
lavorano per potersi avvicinare al mondo
delle stem cioè della scienza della
tecnologia dell'ingegneria e della
matematica
ad un anno dalla scomparsa di mio papà e
dopo un anno a capo dell'azienda la
nostra realtà imprenditoriale cresce del
30 per cento nonostante tutto
anche una donna lo può fare e lo deve
fare
nonostante alcuni pensino che se
stessimo casa
risolveremo il problema della
disoccupazione
in molti altri ci incentivi non
intraprendere certi percorsi perché
prova da marchi ma la resilienza è roba
da donne e se lo è la resilienza lo è la
metalmeccanica e lo è qualsiasi cosa una
donna decida di fare grazie
[Applauso]